welcome back to code vlogs we're on
episode 11 and we are to the point
where we're we should be nearing the end
of this version and we do have base
animations in the engine now as you can
see this dude walking
now it's not fully integrated there's
some things that also need tweaked and
moved over like well it's a lot to
explain but basically i gotta set it up
with all the lighting and make sure
that it's doing the lighting right as it
transforms and then i need to uh add in
the option to switch animations blend
animations and a few other things like
that
that guy's actually really tiny he just
looks big when you're up close but i did
add back in all the the scale and move
stuff too
so
it's coming along pretty good however i
haven't actually put as much time as i
would like to
uh into this in the last few days been a
little under the weather and i kind of
got involved into studying a few other
things which i guess i'll talk about now
i was kind of brushing up on some
algorithm stuff and i came across a list
of 75 leak code problems that basically
every programmer should learn how to do
off the top of their head because these
are problems that come up again and
again in programming and if you know how
to do all 75 of these it should help you
a lot apparently there's actually 76 so
one more got added at some point
but it
yeah the i've went through the first few
uh but there's still a lot more to go so
i'm trying to knock out just one every
once in a while basically and some of
them i find that i kind of know the
answer intuitively and others i have to
really think about
but there's a lot of them to go so
that's another thing that i've been
doing and studying
just to make sure that uh
my skills are up to par
before i continue because it always you
know it always comes back to bite you
when you when you don't study enough and
you try to implement something in a
naive way you just have to spend time on
it again so it really pays off to learn
ahead of time and then come back to the
real problem after you've learned more
i guess that's subjective sometimes
things just need to get done you don't
have time to study anymore but with your
own projects
with no firm deadline you got a little
bit of flex and that's both a good and a
bad thing another thing i've been doing
is just studying vulcan more and more
and making sure i understand it because
at some point we are going to go into
vulcan and this video has kind of given
me some insight and there's some good
links in here for stuff
like uh this faster than light log
by dust in hand
or dust and land and uh yeah i'm
probably gonna go through it at some
point i mean i have the basics of vulcan
but i still needed a bit of a deeper
understanding of all the features and
stuff you gotta set up before i feel
that comfortable implementing it but it
won't be too much longer another thing
i've been doing is just reviewing some
code from well-known open source
projects like
doom 3 and quake
and just seeing how they do things and
taking a look at their shaders and
things like that and it's it's a lot
more than i understand at the moment but
there's a lot of little insights you can
get from here about how to do things and
maybe what you should be doing
or ways that it's been successful in the
past so it's been a pretty cool
experience
and
if you can get these to compile it's
always a nice little milestone as a
programmer to be able to compile tomb
and run it or quake and run it and it's
pretty cool to see like uh the idlib
where they've got all their their math
stuff and there's a bunch of other lives
like i don't even know exactly what all
these are like there's idlib and engine
i was kind of trying to unpack the
difference between those seems like id
live is mostly math stuff and
programming algorithms and stuff like
that and it looks like the engine has
the render sound and ui and just kind of
puts everything together so i thought
that was pretty interesting because the
way i'm doing it in mind i'm pretty much
doing it all in one library it looks
like they separate libraries out which
in a lot of ways makes a lot of sense
like i think timothy is for some kind of
sound so i imagine if we go here and go
to properties
or well i guess uh let's look at the
references you can see what they
reference and it looks like the engine
doesn't reference any of the others so
i'm kind of trying to figure out what
exactly is going on here doom three bfg
uses all these libraries you can see
including the doom classic one
so a lot of interesting stuff like that
you can get like always you know looking
at other people's code you never know
where to start exactly unless you got
some sort of write-up about it
so most of the time you're just kind of
poking around until you figure stuff out
and that's the kind of the way it is
with this right now but it's something
i'm going to continue to come back to
because i find it interesting
and i'm sure i'll learn a lot about
things i'm developing as i go so just
looking at other sources i think is
really important taking time to step
back kind of see a broader view
because when you get deep in the nitty
gritty of something you've been working
on for a long time
you tend to get tunnel vision and who
knows if you're doing it correctly
anymore at that point so that's why i
like to dig in and look at other stuff
it's just to make sure
that i'm doing stuff in somewhat of a
comprehensible way to other people and
and to me because i can i can count
well that can't count the number of
times that i've done something in my
engine and then later realized i've
already i've done this like two
different ways in two different places
and now it's just confusing
i'm sure a lot of you have experienced
that too but i'm looking forward to
advancing this little engine set up and
i'm really thinking about it like do i
really just want one main library that
does everything i kind of do i like that
i i kind of realize that it breaks the
norm because usually you have like a
library for your sound a library for
your other thing and
you know the one for everything but in
this case i just have everything all
piled into one
and i think it's fine it doesn't seem to
bring up any glaring issues other than
maybe the size of it which i'll address
later and you know i could always split
it up later if i wanted to
because right now it's just different
folders like there's all the sound stuff
it's only in these files
and it's still
generally the same there's a few kinks
to work out with how the scene and
render are set up
because there's some mix between scene
and renderer i don't know if i need to
separate them out more or combine them
or
abstract another thing so i'm trying to
make sense of that like for example we
have this model loader and the model
loader essentially you know grabs all
the vertices the textures will combine
with texture letters model loader and
texture loader work together
but
i need to decide whether things are
automatic or more control was given
because what if you want to load a model
but you just want the vertices you
should be able to tell the model loader
not to load textures and what if you're
loading an animated model that's kind of
where i'm at right now you should be
able to say hey i don't want the
animations i just want the mesh or to
say hey i already have the mesh i just
want the animations or the bones and
stuff like that so
there's a lot of just trying to make
sense of the best way to do things once
i change something else that maybe
breaks an old standard i had
then that's when i change things you
know you don't want to change things too
many things at a time
so that's yet another thing i'm really
focusing on and that's the last thing
i'm going to get into in this particular
blog and that relates to version control
and isolating
the things you're working on and
problems you're working on because i
don't know about you but for me as a
solo dev i am
so scatterbrained when i work on this
like
i can't even express
it
so it's something i have to work on it's
to summarize
when i go to work on something say hey i
want to improve these animations
specifically these animations i start
digging into files and i start seeing
stuff that i don't like and i start
changing things i start making comments
i start you know doing stuff that has
nothing to do with animations and then
at some point
i have to like stop myself and be like
what are you doing work on animations
only you're just making this way more
confusing and difficult
for
yourself when you're tweaking other
things because then when i go to like
commit my changes i've got all these
changes that have nothing to do with
animations i've been working on and i'm
just like
uh this is making it so i'm on literally
on the skeletal animation branch and
here i am like tweaking the rendering
and stuff now it's fine if i'm tweaking
the rendering to work with the
animations or something like that but if
i'm just like
poking around doing random stuff that's
an issue
now i will say it's only an issue when
i'm specifically trying to work on one
thing if i'm trying to think how to best
explain this you guys probably get the
point but basically i'm learning to
really like set us when i'm setting
aside time to program
to just really focus on the thing i
actually want to get done like if i say
all right it's time to get the
animations something about them sorted
out i've got a couple hours let's see if
i can get this part complete and maybe
start on the next part if i have time
but then when i start actually going in
there if i start poking around and doing
other things like fixing syntax or
whatever it just messes up my whole flow
and then i have commits in here that
have nothing to do with animation
animations and that's just one example
that goes for every feature i go to add
that's just something i'm learning to
compartmentalize better this is i find
that this is hard specifically on solo
dev projects now i've worked on teams
before and
it was way easier to compartmentalize
when you're on a team because when
you're on a team there's an
understanding of you don't want to touch
other things because other people might
be working on it when you're working on
your own solo project it feels like it
doesn't matter i'm the only one working
on it
it doesn't matter really what i change
no one's going to be affected but that's
not entirely true because i'm affected
and it messes up my flow alright well
thanks for watching peace out guys
[Music]
[Music]
you